rise and join us here in the legislative
office building as representative
cam grills leads us in the pledge of
allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the life of the
united
for states it stands one nation under
god
all
thank you and good morning everyone
we're here today to conduct an executive
session
for the house of science technology and
energy committee and as chair of the
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor is
the result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the science technology
and energy committee actually an
executive session
please note that there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i do confirm that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic reading platform and the
public has access to contemporaneous
and if necessary participate in this
meeting also by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271 three six
zero zero or email hcs
ledge dot state dot nh
dot us the event that the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned
and rescheduled assisting us today
is jennifer four our committee
researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
will be done by roll call vote and if
you're
when we vote so let's start the meeting
by taking
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during the
meeting
that's required under the right to know
law mr clerk
please call the role yes i'd be pleased
to mr chairman
uh representative thomas here
uh representatives harrington notter are
not present at the moment but i
understand they're in leadership and
shall be in so
marked and present okay uh
representative melvin we're substituting
for
representative plenty is here
representative berezini
committee representative bernardi aaron
committee
representative cambrils president
committee representative
president in committee representative
white here in committee
representation yes i'm here
in portsmouth at my home and now i'm all
representative present i'm
at home in my office alone it's possible
there are other people in the house
representative mcgee uh present and
in my office alone president williams
i am here i'm in the car with the kids
representative
i'm present i'm in my home office in
manchester and i'm alone
representative pimentel
representative partial here at home
alone i do believe that
rod pimentel is was online i i am here
um i didn't unmute for some reason
but uh i'm on the patio and my wife is
present as well and probably within
earshot if you're on the patio can we
all join you
you'd be great yeah anyway
thank you i've corrected the record
representative chairman vos
i'm here in the committee room okay
we've got uh 19
representative uh thank you for calling
the role representative
representative callie pitts i see you
have your handwriting yes yes
representative
uh mr chairman i have a problem with
marking somebody present
if they're not physically in the room uh
i'm not physically in the room either
but i'm on the zoom so i i really do
take umbrage with that and i had to call
to get the link
because the link wasn't sent out an hour
before the meeting
so those are two things but i i really
do not believe somebody should be marked
present
until they walk in the room thank you
yes thank you i appreciate your comments
so we're here today to conduct an
executive session
on three senate bills the first of those
bills is senate bill 113
relative to the alternative compliance
payments for renewable
energy obligations not met through the
purchase of renewable energy credits
the second bill that we're going to take
up this morning is senate bill
fn relative to continually appropriating
the renewable energy fund
in the public utilities commission and
then the third and last bill that we
will pick up
is senate bill 91
which is adopting omnibus legislation on
renewable energy
but that's what they came up with
um so we will go through those three
executive sessions during the course of
the rest of the morning here
then we're going to take a break at 12
o'clock
for lunch and then we're gonna come back
at one o'clock
at least all of those who are interested
and can make it
uh can come back at one o'clock for a
presentation
by the governor's office chris elms and
matt maywe
on the department of energy in
house bill 2. so we hope you can make it
for
that presentation so before i move on to
the next order of business i see john
mann has his hand raised
your recognized representative thank you
i just wanted to report i'm here and
alone
in my home i shall correct the record
thank you okay we shall correct the
record
thank you now before we get to our exec
sessions i want to get a sense of the
committee
about what we shall do for
the month of june there are three
mondays in the month of june
available to us to potentially
take up retained bills june 7th
june 14th and june 21st
and of course there's also june 28th but
that's kind of
after we've completed our business so
day to be doing to schedule anything but
what i'd like to do is get a sense for
how the rest of the folks feel
about scheduling work sessions on
retained bills
on the 7th 14th or 21st does
ideas representative flat mr chairman
you may go ahead with any of those dates
but if it's on june 7th i'll be in
florida
okay thank you for that uh
and shall not be joining representative
thomas
so you're gone the 21st you're going the
seventh
anybody else have any uh reaction to the
possibility of
representative
thank you uh i i'd like to see us begin
work
as soon as we can i think we haven't do
do you have a number there uh
mr chairman is the number of retained
bills that we
have currently in hand i do the number
is 14 and i believe either seven or
eight of them
yes uh i'm gonna defer to your wisdom as
uh being a first year
legislator it's they all the dates sound
good and even though i may be out of
town
i certainly feel comfortable with the
zoom platform if that's not uh
unacceptable to continue to join that
way
yes we will continue to have meetings
the way
we've been conducting them all year long
so-called hybrid meetings where um
some of us are in person and some of us
are online so
we will continue that that practice
the other reaction to the idea of
potentially
having work sessions on retained bills
on either the 7th the 14th or the 21st
or possibly
okay i guess i've got a sense of the
committee that we could
probably proceed with that activity so
uh i'll get back to you as soon as i
have scheduling information and we'll
schedule some
work sessions on retain bills so we can
get
some of that work done before fall i
will point out
that the clerk has informed us that
we're not allowed to
vote on these retained bills until next
fall
so the work sessions that we do conduct
will just be simply that work sessions
decide if we want to go forward with a
bill
if we do does it mean amendments
we'll make arrangements to get those
amendments
crafted by ols and then
come fall we'll have one or more exec
sessions
any other uh representative thomas thank
you
yes uh representative harrington is now
in the room
and is present and i suspect
representative notter will
she's following she's going to tell me
to come to this room so
she's fun very soon
so uh as a matter of fact representative
i said you just walked into the room yes
and just wanted to let everybody know
another thing that i should point out to
the rest of the committee is that
representative troy merner is not here
today
but we do have a substitute for
representative murder and that is
representative
charles melville melvin yep
so thank you representative melvin for
being here to
fill in for representative murder
and i might just add on a personal note
that i hope you will all keep
representative myrna and his wife in
your thoughts and prayers
uh they're dealing with some difficult
times right now
okay with that i i did not mr speaker i
did not hear what the last
what are they dealing with i could not
hear you his wife tony
is ill dealing with illness in the
family
i didn't want to get into specifics for
okay let's open the uh executive session
on senate bill 113 and i will recognize
okay representative thomas has moved
that we retain
senate bill 113 representative nader is
recognized
representative notter seconds the motion
that we retain
senate bill 113 as you will recall
when we had the public hearing for
senate bill 113
its prime sponsor senator jeb bradley
asked us to retain the bill
it did contain one section
that senator bradley was hopeful would
move forward
and i have prepared
an amendment to senate bill 78 that adds
that
with that change senate bill 113 i think
can
successfully uh be retained and then we
will
figure out what to do with it later
unfortunately that'll mean we have
15 retained bills instead of 14 but
soviet so is there any further
discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
on the motion to retain senate bill 113.
i'll do that in just one
second
okay uh representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
purpose of the night yes representative
melvin
yes representative platt says yes
representative
berezini yes representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure
yes representative white yes
representative samsic
you're on mute yes
representative man yes representative
yes representative vincent
not president correct representative
mcgee
yes uh
representative williams yes
representative preacher
yes representative pimentel yes
representative paschall yes all right i
have the vote is 20
to zero uh to one not absolutely not not
present
thank you mr clerk chair votes yes uh
i do that all the time because i skip
and then come back and sometimes we get
to come back
what's the number it's vote it's 20
to zero with one not present
okay thank you okay thank you by a vote
of 20 to zero
the motion to retain senate bill 113
passes and so we will close
the executive session on senate bill 1-3
okay
question mr chairman given the vote
could that go on the consent calendar no
calendar doesn't go on all right
thank you so make sure i look there okay
so now let's move on uh
i'll open the exact session on senate
bill 78
dash fn which is a bill
relative to continually appropriating
the new renewable energy fund for the
public utilities commission
relative to clarifying certain elections
renewable energy
classification and i'll recognize
representative
thomas thank you mr chair um
i make a motion to adopt amendment 2021
1562h
representative thomas moves to the
adoption of amendment 2021
1562 h the chair recognizes
representative notter
representative knotter seconds the
2021-1562h
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the adoption
right uh
uh
representative thomas votes yes uh
representative harrington
yes representative notter yes
representative
uh representative platt votes yes
representative bereshni yes
representative
bernardi yes representative kimbrough
yes representative pleasure yes
representative white
yes representative samsic yes
yes representative mann yes
president yes representative vincent not
president
representative mcgee yes representative
williams
yes representative preacher yes
representative pimentel yes
representative paschal yes
representative
did yes hit everybody i think i did so
the vote
is uh 20 to zero to uh one not present
okay thank you so amendment 20 21
1562 h is adopted
the chair now recognizes representative
thomas for a motion
thank you mr chair by motion uh on
fp78
representative thomas recommends or
moves that
we otpa senate bill 78
chair recognizes representative notter
representative nodder seconds to motion
is there
any further discussion on senate bill 78
i will point out
the amendment we just adopted includes
on lines
25 through 27
the section of
senate bill 113 that allows hydrogen
hydrogen derived from water to be
eligible for the renewable portfolio
standard
as requested by representative merner
and by senator bradley any further
discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
on the motion to otp a senate bill
78.
sorry this is coming at you so fast and
furious
it would be impossible except they
prepared and advance
all of these uh with the exception of
the amendment i did not expect
early on i took care of that as well
uh rep this is on hb 78 representative
thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative nader
representative plettvolt's guest
representative berezni
yes representative bernardi yes
representative campbells
yes representative pleasure yes
representative white
yes representative samsic yes
representative kelly pest
yes represent not present
representative mckee yes president
mcwilliams
yes represent a creature
yes representative yes
representative partial yes okay
uh rep chairman votes chair votes yes uh
did you call representative oxendine's
name
i thought i had okay yes i was called
and i responded thank you sir
so this vote is again 20
to zero to one not present
and given that mr chair let me save this
i asked since this is an autopsy with
uh with the amendment uh
i 20.
and without objection we'll place this
uh bill on the consent calendar
as senate bill 78 passes 20 to nothing
that was my question thank you one
question
[Music]
i'll get clarification from the clerk on
that if he says yes and we'll put it on
otherwise all right i'm marking your
concern for the moment
okay all right so let's uh close the
public hearing
on senate bill 78. now we will open the
on senate bill 91 and
the chair will recognize representative
thomas for motion
chair mr chair i motioned to
adopt amendment 2021-16-19h
for sb-91
okay representative thomas moves the
adoption of
amendment 2021-1619-h
chair recognizes representative knotter
representative nader seconds the motion
to adopt
amendment 2021 16-19
h is there any discussion representative
mcgee yes thank you mr chairman
um i was reviewing this last evening and
i noted that we had
when we had discussed the amendment that
was going to be put into ols we said
that parts 2
and 3 were not going to be edited and
in section 2 specifically some of the
language changes here
are problematic and so i just wanted to
bring it to your attention that we had
not discussed this
uh as a committee or in public hearings
none of these changes were agreed to
um so they kind of come out of nowhere
for the exec session which is
unfortunate i think um so i
we had discussed uh the changes that
would happen in parts one
and four uh and the removal of section
five
but um but especially the language
in section two that removes the
well-established language
of an avoidance of unjust and
unreasonable cost shifting which is
um well-known nomenclature in the public
utilities commission for them having to
vet
the fact that no undue cost shifting
will occur
to this very specific and black and
white language which
um is not well understood and
seems kind of arbitrary it just i don't
understand where it came from
but i know that in our committee we did
not discuss it
and so i just wanted to bring that to
your attention because
we had an agreement of what the
amendment would include and my
understanding is that there's
i've just printed an additional
amendment that doesn't include that
language i believe that
representative oxenous put in because um
you know it it's upsetting to see that
this is not what we all discussed and
agreed to
okay thank you uh i'll respond to you
representative mcgee by saying that
as i explained in the email that i sent
to everyone excuse me could you just
get closer to the microphone speak a
as i pointed out in the email that i
sent out on friday afternoon
after considerable discussion with
members of the republican caucus both on
the committee
and in the larger caucus
there was some uh concern about the
language
that was added to house bill 315
senate bill 109 and
the caucus felt that some further
language
clarifying our position on cost shifting
would be warranted and so that's why we
added this
uh language to section two as you point
out
it is black and white language
whereas the language that was struck out
an avoidance of unjust and unreasonable
cost shifting
could be interpreted to mean that there
is
just and reasonable cost shifting
whereas
the uh the republican caucus
uh does not share that opinion so
this language is the statute of the
public utilities commission you're not
recognized to speak
okay so this clarifies for the public
utilities commission just exactly
what kinds of cost shifting
the republican caucus thinks is prudent
public policy
so that's why this was added to the
amendment
question
you're on mute thank you very much
um the problem here is that by taking
away the well-established standard of
just and reasonable or
unjust and unreasonable you
this language creates a completely new
standard that has no place
has never appeared before in any of our
regulatory law
and it's a standard that literally
cannot be implemented
by the puc insurer means either
guarantee
or make certain cost shifting happens
all
the time if i go away for a week and my
neighbor is paying
his rates and i'm paying my rates i've
had his electricity as its cost shifted
to me
if people put in energy efficiency
measures
and they reduce their load there's a car
shifting
it's it's pervasive what what i think
you are
trying to accomplish here is that you
want to
minimize unnecessary or
burdensome uh cost shifting
you know we we often talk about rough
justice um
in terms of rate setting it can't be
perfect
and with this language if something is
one tenth of a percent of a kilowatt
hour off
it's a violation you know the puc stands
would be tied
so um i think that if you would if you
need to clarify your position which i
think is well established
but if you feel the need to have that in
statute
you could use language about minimizing
uh minimizing to the extent practicable
um there there is language that could be
used
but uh the term ensure
is a is a real red flag here and
particularly as
representative mcgee has said to to try
to create a whole new standard in law
that didn't come from the senate it
wasn't in their version wasn't had
uh didn't have a public hearing wasn't
discussed in our work session
i'm i i think this would really be an
extraordinarily
uh bad step um
[Music]
and i think at least at this point
that's that's enough to i
i do have an amendment uh which
hopefully will reach us from ols
which is to just return to the original
language
uh just and reasonable really will carry
the day
but if if you feel a need to clarify
that it has arrived is that what you're
telling me
oh great thank you um and there is a
one very very small change about the
number of members
uh that's the only other change in that
amendment thank you
okay thank you representative harrington
is recognized thank you mr chairman i
probably should have caught this earlier
so i'll apologize in advance
if you look on page four of the amended
bill on line
uh 19 through 21
cards primary energy an energy form
found in nature that has not been
subject to any human engineered
conversion
it goes on to list various ones
including nuclear
that sentence makes no sense because
any nuclear power plant every nuclear
power plant in the united states
is been subject to uh engineering
conversion because it uses enriched
uranium
uh if you want to go to canada it might
work with a
they don't enrich the uranium but it's
still kind of hard to say it's not
processed so
i'm just not sure what that statement's
getting us but
uh it just it doesn't make sense
it's it's not simply not accurate you
have to
have a human engineered conversion in
order to produce nuclear power
there's no full nuclear power that you
just dig it up out of the ground and
throw it in the bucket and
watch it go so it doesn't really make
sense
i don't know if we could just delete
nuclear or
i'm not i'm trying to still trying to
figure out the intent of that but that
gets that whole statement that it's not
i mean even
if you look at oil or natural gas i mean
it's been
taken out it's been refined it's been
processed
so this whole idea of human engineered
conversion process
i'm not sure what it means is what it
gets us
that representative fled is recognized i
think that
thank you mr chair i think the tail end
of what representative harrington said
uh puts it in context uh because
oil has been at least filtered and maybe
had additives
uh uh coal has been washed uh
and and maybe been de-sulfurized to a
certain extent
um and uh so so i mean they're all
subject to some human engineering i i i
think it's it's uh
the intent was uh for for energy
conversion
so none of them have done any any uh
human
engineering for energy conversion it's a
pre-process
of what i'm saying it just doesn't make
sense
maybe well i agree with you that that
and i didn't catch this either the the
phrase human engineered conversion
process probably isn't necessary
obviously the intent of this paragraph
is to define primary energy
sources
although it doesn't actually say primary
energy sources but
that would seem to be the intent i think
given the late
hour that that's not something we can
fix
maybe that's something that one of you
could
think about fixing with new legislation
next fall
i just wanted to bring into the
calling in from mars okay
uh sorry about that um uh
i i wanted to uh uh underscore uh what
uh uh senator harrington uh represented
harrington just said
uh i totally agree with him that at this
point that
really doesn't belong there um i i
i think most people think of primary
energy
and secondary energy in the terms of
how much energy do you lose when you go
from primary to secondary
but it is true that nuclear energy is
not considered a primary energy source
as
it comes out of the ground like oil does
maybe or coal
but anyway i want to also
remind people i think it was
representative harrington who pointed
out
about the issue of uh the cost shifting
involved here in the
paragraph we're talking about i believe
that he
mentioned that he doesn't think that
it's practical to be able to
do that to guarantee that there is no
shifting going on
because like like was mentioned before
there's always shifting going on
and so it seems to me it makes a lot of
sense just to keep it at something
that's a standardized
uh version of what the puc has been
using
that is unjust and unreasonable cost
shifting or maybe to include
what was suggested minimizing cost
shifting but
i think it's it's uh and maybe
representative harrington can correct me
i believe he was the one who mentioned
that before thank you
thank you representative i would point
out that this language
instructs the commission when it
develops alternative tariffs
to allow for minimal
caution such as allowances for metering
and building
so the language isn't
totally black and white there is some
flexibility there and i think that would
cover
the issues that representative
harrington
mentioned earlier am i correct about
that representative
yes it does thank you okay thank you
so uh thank you representative samson
representative mcgee you have another
comment i do thank you it's along those
same lines um
i was just thinking you mentioned that
that the gop
caucus had input to the bill and wanted
this
approach you know in this bill and
i i think that there are certainly you
know
philosophies that different people hold
in terms of what they think
should be placed in statute but
i feel like our committee has a
responsibility to make sure that the
statutes are consistent with themselves
and that we're
we're the ones that have the knowledge
of how the system
operates or most of us you know are
familiar with
how the public utilities commission
operates and
they already have the charge in their
mission the way they
operate is to make sure that that that
cost shifting doesn't happen that's
but they're given the latitude in the
statute because
they're an agency that we have given
that
authority to and so this is a hand tying
thing
which i feel is really inappropriate and
if it's going to be
if it's going to be imposed from an
ideological position then it's just bad
policy
because and i think that we as the
gatekeepers
on our committee should be the ones that
stop
that type of bad policy from going into
place because it's
almost being put in there as though
the puc needs to be policed which they
don't
there's no evidence that they do so i
you know i think that's my position is
that
there is no evidence that the public
utilities commission as an
agency is doing any of these things
incorrectly
and so this seems to be a solution
without a problem
and i would i would really ask my
republican colleagues to
reconsider uh allowing that language to
remain because
it does nothing to help any of the
implementation of policies that we have
um and it and again it assumes a wrong
thank you representative mcgee i'd
remind
you representative mcgee and other
members of your caucus that
i've heard all of you state in
public hearings before this committee on
many occasions
that there is no cost shifting in net
metering
and if you are correct about that then
this language will have no
significant effect therefore uh
if the republican caucus feels that it's
prudent
public policy which is the message
that i get from my colleagues in the
republican practice
then we probably have a minor
disagreement about
that issue mr chair follow-up
follow-up because you're you're you're
missing as soon as i finish my comment
sure
sure so as i was saying
the republican caucus feels this is
prudent public policy
now you may disagree with that but which
is you're right
but that is the public policy direction
that we are going to take in this
particular instance
okay representative mcgee you're right
yeah follow-up
thank you for your indulgence dilliance
mr chair um
what i would say is that the um evidence
that has been provided
has concluded that there is no
discernible cost shifting and that's
so that's an evidence-based decision
it's not our opinion
putting in language that now there is no
latitude
does something different because as rep
representative oxendine was saying cost
shifting in terms of absolutes
like the fact that somebody's using
somebody's not where it's going to
who's paying what that is an impossible
task
so what we're doing is we're setting
forth in statute
language that is unattainable right it's
not stopping
cost shifting from happening it's
stopping the public utilities commission
from being able to do
anything because anything will
involve costs moving around
we have to have someone do an assessment
to bring information to us
if adding distributed energy resources
to the system
is ever starting to shift in terms of
people who are non
you know who are rate payers but are not
participating in that market are then
getting some of those costs we have no
evidence that that has happened to this
point because we have very little
penetration
but we also have requested of the public
utilities commission
that they provide evidence to us on an
ongoing
basis right they're supposed to report
to us annually
so we have a way to address it if there
is an
issue but what this does is it creates
an issue for the public utilities
commission which is why i would again
protest that this is not a good policy
thank you representative mcgee
representative harrington is recognized
thank you mr chairman i just might note
here that we're dealing with a very
small population this is not the
customer base as a whole
we're only talking about customer
generators which there are going to be
very very few
so it's not like everybody that's an
electric meter is covered by this it's
very specific to them
and it tells the puc how to do it and i
see no problem with the language
thank you representative oxendine is
recognized
thank you mr chair i must say i
am rather flummoxed that as a former puc
commissioner
representative harrington does not
perceive a difficulty with this
impossible standard being put into law
um moving right along uh however from
that
the puc has an ongoing
docket in in it which has to do
with the value of this kind of
generation
and we are waiting for the outcome of
that pending that the puc
has stated that there is no significant
cost shifting attached to this and and
and this is where discernible
significant significance is the word
that has been
codified because as as we said
costs move around and and no two
customers are ever
exactly the same what what this is doing
is
making it impossible for there to be a
successful
net metering rate making case in the
future because the puc's hands will be
tied
this this is an attempt to slip in a
whole new standard into law and a
workable standard
one that is impossible to achieve
um you may say it's very few uh
at the moment but we're not making
law here just for the moment we're
this is this is becoming part of the
rsas this
this will will continue to fester it
will continue to stand
as an impediment because those agency
personnel who are trying to do what the
legislature is directing them
will go to this and say it looks like
they you know they had a discussion they
knew it was an impossible standard and
they voted for it anyway
what does that tell you they don't want
okay thank you representative oxendine
the chair now recognizes
uh representative harrington did you
want to respond to uh representative
oxendine
not worth it okay thank you uh
representative samson
is recognized i object yes thank you mr
chairman uh
to your comment that we democrats have
been saying
that there's no cost shifting going on i
i want to
just amplify what has been just said
that finding was a puc finding from
2017 order number two six
cola uh cohen's or come out zero two
nine
in that puc finding they were the ones
who said that there was
quote little to no evidence of any
significant cost shifting
due to net metering so it's not just us
who are just coming out of the blue with
with this kind of statement the puc said
this that's why we are
quoting it now if the puc says something
different
we would probably decide to quote that
as well
but right now that is the last quote we
heard on this thank you
thank you representative samsung i would
point out that that very same
order that you're reading from also
contains
text from the consumer advocate that
says
that net readering does ship costs and
that
the commission investigated
investigation of alternative net
metering tariffs
should account for that
and ameliorate it where possible
i've read that order numerous times
and that one quote that you cherry
picked
does not take a full picture
of what the commission order said
on that proceeding all right are there
any uh
further representative flett is
recognized i would just say that that
as you say cherry pick quote i've heard
several times
from the democrats and if that's true
this has no
uh representative bernardi is recognized
for a comment
yes i i would just like to point out
that
up to this point uh net beatering is
at the one megawatt and below but we
have been considering multiple pieces of
legislation that would expand net
metering
to a much higher rate and therefore
we believe it's very important that the
issue of cost shifting
be part of the equation that the puc
looks at
and ensures that there is no
cost shifting particularly when we go to
these higher
thank you representative bernardi does
anyone else have any
further discussion here
representative berezin thank you i'll
just add that
this does say except for minimal
allowances for international buildings
so this is not an absolute no costume it
does allow you for pointing that out
uh representative oxendine you still
have your hand up
please you've already been recognized
twice to speak
no speeches are allowed if you have a
valid point to make that would be
acceptable but please don't
go into a long speech
and you're on you as well
thank you very much uh yes uh the point
was just made that
this um has a latitude the latitude is
very specific and very limited and does
not cover
this new broad-based standard
of ensuring which means to guarantee or
make
certain words such as ameliorate
words such as maximize something to the
extent practicable
any of those could could meet the
concerns that we've raised here but
honestly i i think the best thing for us
to do
is to leave the language as it is and as
you have suggested in
other portions of this bill let someone
bring forward legislation in the fall
good suggestion thank you
representatives uh representative kelly
pets is recognized
i'm i'm looking at the amendment i'm
just wondering
when the puc goes through its procedure
to enact this amendment
and to make this is going to be a couple
of years i'm
i'm guessing and that
to ensure all that these the data is
correct and again
ensure so
my question to the chair would be should
we
sacrifice the good for the perfect i
believe that in
the when the puc goes through this they
will not be able to
ensure that
costs are not shifted in some way
any a big way or a small way i don't
know
and it will take them at least a couple
of years to do that would
is that a fair estimate on my part
i think that's fair the alternative net
metering tariff uh docket is still open
at the puc it's been open for
three years now maybe yeah
uh and there are a couple of studies
that were commissioned as part of that
docket
that have yet to be completed and once
those studies are completed
then they can move forward with
potential
the development of potential new tariffs
so it could be some time you're right
before they have to deal with this
language nevertheless
it is important to the republican caucus
this language be there so that when they
do
start deliberating on future alternative
net tutoring tariffs
that they understand that this is an
important principle
under which they should conduct
okay i think we've had adequate uh
comment on this uh amendment so i would
like
uh to now ask the clerk to call the role
on the adoption of amendment 2021-1619-h
mr clerk thank you mr chairman i'm just
taking certain i have the right document
up and i do
uh this i've got like three different
amendment documents
all set up uh representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative notter
yes representative melvin yes
representative plett votes yes
representative barishni
yes professor bernardi yes
representative campbells
yes representative pleasure yes
representative white
yes representative samsic now
yes representative mcmahon
no representative oxidant no
representative vince is not present
uh representative mcgee count
i assume that representative williams is
on mute
representative williams i'll come back
no no represent creature
now representative pimentel
no representative pasha
no okay uh so
by a vote of 12 to eight with one not
present
the adoption of the where the
amendment is adopted the chair now
recognizes
representative thomas for a motion thank
you mr chair uh
that's the motion on the floor okay the
motion was what
you can hear as amended
current amendment all right and my
question remains my motion
okay chair recognizes representative
knotter from
my second promotion okay it's been moved
and seconded to adopt
uh senate bill 91 as amended
and is there any further discussion i
would point out
to the committee that i have had a
discussion with
senator avar the chair of senate energy
and he has indicated that he will concur
with
the amendment we made to sign senate
bill
representative oxendine you have a
comment
yes thank you very much i'm seconding
the clerk's question as to what's going
to happen with um
in particular my amendment will it be
considered
excuse me mr chair am i correct
in assuming that if this vote
for the bill with this amendment fails
then other amendments would be
considered
seeing none i would ask the clerk to
mr chairman does uh representative kelly
pitts have her hand up for something
yeah she may but we're in the voting
mode so
we'll have to take that comment later
okay representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative inaudible
yes representative melvin yes
representative pledge votes yes
representative
yes representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's
yes representative yes representative
white
yes representative no representative
kelly pitts
no representative man hello
i'm the president that's right
representative mcgee
no representative williams no
representative creature no
representative pimentel
no president partial no
uh representative a chairman votes
chair votes yes okay that's
uh
12.
well as i said two one two three
four five nine one eleven
eleven it's eleven who am i missing
one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven you're right
okay by a vote of 11 to nine
the senate bill 91
is moved out to pass as
adopted so thank you all i will close
the public hearing on senate bill 91.
now representative callie pitts did you
have a question that you wanted to
raise no
okay uh mr chairman uh
mr representative sam search is
recognized will there be a
majority and minority report absolutely
if you have a minority report please
submit it
by close of business tomorrow
okay it's tuesday afternoon by five
o'clock come on
representative oxendine would you be
willing to do that
okay so uh
we are going to take an extended lunch
break
and we will return to the committee room
at one o'clock for a presentation
on the department of energy
in hb2 which will be made by the
governor's office
chris elms and matt may and
i hope you can all tune in for that it
should be
enlightening i know there have been a
few amendments made in the senate
that may change some of the details
involved in the department of energy so
you'll all want to
tune in if you can to learn about those
so we will see you all at one o'clock
and enjoy your lunch
um
so
yes i can great thank you very much
sure just to let everybody know uh
i'm still going to start this meeting uh
very shortly
after one o'clock but we're going to
wait a couple of minutes to allow people
to get back from lunch
sorry i was muted hey representative how
fascists
matt used to be one of the people that
used to watch us
how you doing matt and chris nice to see
you
good representative good to see you as
well
representatives officers you're gonna be
listening to tunes while this is going
on
excuse me are you going to be listening
to tunes while this is going on
i hope not no i think this is more
interesting
unless somebody wants to have some
background music
i've never seen you with headphones on
before
uh that's because my my wife is next to
me she's just finishing something and
[Music]
representative mcgee you're muted i
think you were trying to
say something how are you yeah i was
just saying we have two offices in this
house
that very purpose when your kids move
out you convert
hi matt nice to see you
all right these two gentlemen good to
see you as well
these two gentlemen uh chris elms and
matt maywe
have graciously agreed to do a
presentation and i know they're both
busy men so i don't want to
keep them any longer that is absolutely
necessary so let's get this
meeting underway i know there are still
a few folks who are with us this morning
that are not online
i'm not sure if that means they won't be
here or
if they're just tardy getting back from
lunch
but in any case let's start this
presentation i will turn the floor
over to chris elms and matt mayu from
the governor's office gentlemen
take it right away thank you mr chairman
and thank you for the invite to appear
before science technology
and energy the presentation i have for
you today is the same presentation i
offered to the senate finance committee
last week at this time and we apologize
for
needing to reschedule from last week but
we were very excited to see a bipartisan
six to one vote out of the senate
finance committee
for the department of energy proposal
with the accompanying amendments and i'm
happy to review the amendment as well
um but i think this will be a good
conversation today happy to take
questions as we go along
i know there's been plenty of
conversations about the department what
some of its goals are
and happy just provide the committee an
overview happy to get deep into the
weeds
on energy policy it's great to see a lot
of
the familiar faces and for the reps on
ft e that i haven't met before
i used to be the governor's energy
advisor prior to stepping into this role
as budget director
so i am again more than happy to have a
deep policy conversation
on any of these topics as well but with
that why don't we jump in
and give you a brief 40 000 foot
overview what the proposal is
would be to combine the energy functions
of the office of strategic initiatives
with portions of the public utilities
commission
and ultimately we see this as an
opportunity
to reach better outcomes whether it be
for ratepayers
or even just to give energy policy a
singular home here in the state of new
hampshire
so the new department of energy
structure would be
that single entity if you will for
energy policy decision making here in
new hampshire
and we're able to leverage some of those
non-regulatory functions
of what the current public utilities
commission does
unify those with the energy components
of
the office of strategic initiatives and
form this new department out of
existing pieces within state government
from there we would separate the
non-energy functions that currently
exist at osi
to the department of business and
economic affairs
with one small program the conservation
land stewardship program
going to the department of
administrative services
as for the puc which again is the
existing regulatory body
that is entirely reorganized within the
department of energy
and i'll also note that this proposal
does not make any changes to the office
of the consumer advocate
or the site evaluation committee beyond
just changing
their administrative attachments where
they get their administrative back
office support
would change from the puc to the
for those and i'm sure this committee is
a familiar with osi
and its various functions but for those
that might
not necessarily have the same level of
exposure to it
osi is part of the governor's office as
part of the executive department
and functions functions as the
governor's office for energy policy
as well as administering various federal
programs
like the low-income heating assistance
program
the weatherization program the state
energy program
and really serves as a pass through for
those federal dollars that come into the
state and then are disbursed out into
the community
to assist some of those critical income
qualified programs
but it's also important to note that osi
as currently constructed
constructed uh does a variety of other
things as well
everything from the u.s census to
monitoring state
land easements the national flood
insurance program
offering assistance to municipal
planning agencies or planning boards
and really has become a catch-all if you
will at one point osi administered
the governor's scholarship program and
needless to say is not the entity that
is able to focus a hundred percent of
its time
on energy policy and that's one of the
things that we hope to
rectify through this new organization of
state government
really keep some of these different
policy areas uh better aligned as
opposed
to having this um an alphabet soup if
you will
the way osi currently is structured
some of the overall policy goals like i
said
we see this as a great way to unify
energy efforts in the state
but the other two areas i really want to
focus on
are how the commission the puc currently
operates
um allows for at the very least a
perceived conflict of interest
in the dual role that staff occupies
so commissioned staff presently are able
to
be a party to the docket help build
the evidentiary record present
evidence before the commission but then
also
advise the commission outside the
hearing room on
how they should rule on any given docket
imagine if the prosecutor also sat
on the jury a similar similar type of a
concept
um what we're hoping to do by creating
this new department of energy
is establish a bright red line
essentially you either
work as an advisor to the commissioners
and help them
rule on a given docket issue their order
think of it similar to a clerk or a
judge
or the other alternative is that you
work for the department
you represent the interests of the state
and you make your case in the hearing
room
but never behind closed doors so again
that bright red line that
degree of separation we think will not
only allow the commission to operate
better and more effectively
but also resolve some again this
perception
that staff plays in both arenas if you
will
the other critical policy goal from this
proposal
is adding accountability from governor
and council and this is something that
every other state agency
has this level of accountability the puc
as it's currently structured
only the commissioners are confirmed by
governor and council
they served six-year terms this proposal
wouldn't change that
but what it would add is additional
accountability
for the division directors which
currently are
chosen by the puc but never need to be
brought forward
for a formal confirmation process so in
the new department of energy you would
have the commissioner
the deputy commissioner and the four
division directors that we'll touch on
a little bit later all serve on set
four-year terms and again require
governor and council
moving on to some of the financials this
proposal does
modestly save general funds
we're talking 250 000
a year which out of a 13.5 or 13.6
billion dollar budget
is certainly nothing to write home about
but the reason i include this is just to
show that we're not expanding government
we're not asking
the general fund to foot a larger bill
as part of this proposal
and the reason we find these
efficiencies are really the back office
components
unifying the pucs back office without
parts of osi
and similarly at the department of
business and economic affairs
so again essentially from a general fund
perspective it's net negative
and that's largely just going from three
if you do look in the budget book you
will see that there is a
total budget increase but what's
important to note is
the vast majority of that increase was
explained by
projections that the puc makes on
how much auction money the regional
greenhouse gas initiative
reggie those quarterly auctions bring in
for the state
and as i'm sure this committee is well
aware the vast majority of those dollars
are rebated back
to rate payers both commercial and
residential rate payers
and that is something that certainly
shows up on the budget as a grant
that goes out to ratepayers
but does you know artificially inflate
if you will
what what the department's budget would
be because of that grant line
puc chairwoman diane martin wrote a memo
to the house finance committee
uh about three months ago now explaining
that
component and how those uh analyses are
done and
ultimately what gets uh pushed back out
the door
but but certainly happy to provide that
memo to the committee as well
and here you just see the the budget
changed by the different sources of
funds
you see the the largest increases are
in federal funds so again more federal
dollars coming into the state
whether it be for energy efficiency
through the weather
weatherization program or the low-income
uh
fuel assistance program you'll see the
decrease in general funds
again modest all things considered
and then that increase in other funds
again tied to the reggie auction revenue
and there you see the breakdown across
as we had promised during the house
phase
we knew that this was a large proposal
we knew that we wanted to make sure that
the final product had deep stakeholder
input
so we made some technical amendments on
the house side
before their april 8 deadline and then
brought
a second amendment to the senate finance
committee
with additional technical corrections we
heard from stakeholders regarding
the organization of certain positions
how the i.t costs would be structured
what types of physical distancing we
would want to see
from the department staff versus the
commission staff
and incorporated all of that different
feedback
whether it was from clean energy groups
or regulated industry
or just people that interface with the
commission on a regular basis
we wanted to make sure that the final
product we put forward
would resolve those long-standing
challenges uh and we're very
excited to have had amendment 1520s
incorporated into house bill 2
and i think it had again a broad
bipartisan support which is recognized
not only in stakeholder comments
but also in the 6-1 vote out of the
senate finance committee
one of the things that we certainly
heard during the house phase is
how many lawyers the commission would
need to have in this new structure
and as part of this amendment that we
brought forward and was voted on last
week
we've added more lawyers back to the
public utilities commission we've
brought the clerk's office back over
and there was another amendment brought
by senator bradley
to bring the general counsel position
out of the department of energy
and put it back at the public utilities
commission
so i will say i really think this
process has been very collaborative has
been very effective
i think everyone has had a chance to
have their voice heard
and it's been a resounding yes that this
department of energy proposal
is the right path forward for the state
of new hampshire
two other things that i'll touch on here
one of which being the site evaluation
committee
we know there's been a lot of
conversation not only in the legislature
but also a governor and council
we didn't make any policy changes to the
sec during the budget
but we did charter a study committee to
evaluate what necessary changes might
be needed that committee would have
three members of the house two members
of the senate
and work on a very tight timeline over
the summer
i believe the final report is due
october 1st
but wanting to make sure that the
overall mission of the sec is being
achieved
that the financing and funding structure
aligns with how other states do similar
work
and rectify some of those ongoing
monitoring and compliance issues
that we know have bubbled up over the
past several years
of the current structure so again no
hard and fast policy changes but we're
very excited for what
future legislation that study committee
might recommend separately and this is
something i should have led with off the
top
when it comes to the genesis of this
idea for department of energy
the credit really does come back to the
science technology and energy committee
through house bill 156 from 2019
which was the study commission that
really kicked off these conversations in
earnest
and former chairman bob backus
representative backus from manchester
um you know really was the leader of
that uh
initiative he chaired that study
commission and a lot of those
conversations certainly
influenced the direction that we headed
in the governor's budget
um and again i think that's just spoken
to the broad bipartisan buy-in
that we've seen for this idea so
obviously uh
thank thanks where thanks is due and
again this committee certainly
had a large role uh prior to the session
in shaping what some of those
conversations
would look like flipping now just to
some of what the actual organization
charts would look like at this
department
dea you see the osi division of planning
essentially being picked up and
relocated and dropped back down
with no real changes you see those
positions things that offer municipal
assistance
operate the state data center gis census
things of that nature
i know commissioner caswell is very
excited to have these functions
uh be fitted into bea he definitely sees
the
nexus in his department's mission with
this component of osi
and we're very excited for for this new
unification
at das i mentioned the conservation land
stewardship program
would become administratively attached
this is a two-person program
that monitors state easements whether it
be for
natural and cultural resources or fish
and game
and a function that has been located osi
previously
and now would just be administratively
attached to administrative services
this is a self-funded program based on a
dedicated account
for that ongoing monitoring of these
properties
and then transitioning here into the
department of energy
what you see here is division level
breakdown so starting in the top
left corner the office of the consumer
advocate
no changes would be administratively
attached to the department
on the top right you see the site
evaluation committee again
no changes administratively attached
the adjudicative commissioners
accounting in 1892
second from the left this is where the
regulatory functions of the puc would be
located
so you would have the adjudicated
commissioners the three quasi judicial
commissioners that oversee dockets
with their staff and i'll touch on
exactly what staff that looks like in a
bit later
and then sliding over one to the office
of the commissioner
would be the new agency head for this
department
very similar to environmental services
or any one of those
other state agencies that has a single
agency head
with several division directors below
them and there would be four divisions
in this proposal
administrative support which would be
the back office the accounting functions
the legal division that would provide
support
not only to the department but also the
puc
site evaluation committee and the office
of the consumer advocate
uh as a central services model right to
provide
um administrative back-end support to
each of those different entities
and then below that you see the other
three divisions policy and programs
enforcement and regulatory um and i'll
start flipping through these here
so you see the commissioner's office the
commissioner and the deputy
and then here in policy and programs
this is where the
energy components of osi would be
inserted into so you see things like the
weatherization program the fuel
assistance program
as well as some of the more policy
driven elements of the current puc
things that don't really fit in a
regulatory entity
uh and those would be things like the
sustainable energy division
which offers grants and rebates for
consumers that install renewable energy
things like the offshore wind office
which is funded for the first time
in this budget proposal the nesco
manager which is how the state
interacts at a regional and a federal
level
on policy beyond our state borders
and lastly the consumer director so any
of those
customer service elements that the puc
does that don't really fit within a
regulatory model
now here under the department of energy
moving over to the division of
enforcement these would be things like
the audit division that currently exists
at the puc
the safety division uh things
like gas pipeline safety those programs
which again aren't truly regulatory in
nature um would fit here under the
department
and also any of the investigations this
could be things
um either compliance issues uh or other
investigatory elements of what might
exist within
a department of energy setting
and then finally the regulatory division
this is where the puc staff
would participate in dockets on behalf
of the public interest representing the
interests of the state
would appear before the public utilities
commission
and these are existing divisions at the
puc so things like the electric division
and the gas and water division would be
located here within the department of
energy this division
would automatically be a party to any
puc proceeding
so that they would have the duty and the
obligation
to appear before the commission to
address the state's position and also
contribute to filling a complete docket
for the commission ultimately to issue
an order on
but that's the model that we see here
this here would be the support division
so things like it
the business office federal grants
compliance
and the legal division you'll notice in
the top row the general counsel
a senate amendment did move that from
this division
into the public utilities commission i
apologize you didn't update the slide
but that would be the one change on this
particular slide that you see
the office of the consumer advocate as i
mentioned there are no changes in this
budget proposal
but this is their current five-person
staff
similarly on the site evaluation
committee no changes to personnel
but we did include language for that
study committee
um to look at future changes that might
be necessary
and then lastly the adjudicative
commissioners or this is the the public
utilities commission as it would be
reformed
you see the three commissioners that
oversee the agency
led by the chairman and adding
again the clerks filing administrator
administrative assistants and an
attorney into this
new entity or this recreated entity
to make sure that they have the direct
support that they need
and then the six senior advisor
positions
which would be those staff roles that
never would appear before the commission
in dockets
but would help them issue orders and
come to their decision making
on the issues that are pending before
the commission so that's the role that
we've envisioned
i'll stop there like i said more than
happy to take questions
i know that there's a lot to digest here
i am happy to share the amendment with
the committee as well
mostly reference changes and just
technical cleanup
the bulk of what we did again was
solicit that stakeholder feedback and
make sure that the right entity
had the right powers and the right
duties uh to carry out this mission
should this stay in the budget and
should the budget pass and we're very
excited for for these changes to take
effect
uh and look forward to um again better
outcomes for rate payers and i think it
goes without saying that governor sununu
uh has been the fiercest advocate
fiercest advocate for residential
ratepayers especially
throughout his time in office and we see
this as part and parcel
of that past policy thank you mr
chairman
thank you uh mr melo appreciate you
giving us that presentation
uh mr elms is there anything you want to
add to uh
mr melo's comments no
i think matt summed that up pretty
pretty well but uh yeah definitely happy
to take questions
okay uh representative callie pitts is
don't forget to unmute i want to be
recognized
um why does this particular
formation of an agency belong in the
finance
committee and not in the energy
committee
and in the back of the budget it would
seem that this is a policy
so could you answer that for me sure and
thank you for the question
representatives and
i apologize that i didn't dive into this
uh during the presentation but
when it comes to reorganizations of
state government
whether it was splitting apart dread in
2017 or the formation of the department
of military affairs
and veterans services in 2019
whenever you're moving different parts
of state government around
those have been traditionally done
through house bill 1 and house bill 2.
so this is certainly keeping with past
practice
and we do feel confident that what we've
put forward because of the work
of the study commission to establish a
department of energy
because of that work that predated the
budget
uh we certainly feel that this policy
has been vetted
and again i think the broad bipartisan
support for these changes has
spoken to the the process that we've
gone through
can i follow up follow up
uh as far as funding for the puc
and it's my understanding and it may not
be that
the majority of the funding comes from
the ratepayers so is are the rate payers
now
going to fund the department of energy
so the ratepayers would still fund any
direct work that's done for regulation
so yes some of those utility assessment
dollars
would go to the department of energy but
it's important to note that there are
other funding sources
such as reggie such as the renewable
energy fund
and especially the federal dollars
almost all of what's being pulled in
from the office of strategic initiatives
thank you okay uh representative mcgee
is recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
melo for taking my question
um i had a bunch of questions from the
original language which i understand
has been modified since it's gotten over
to the senate
um one of the things that was concerning
to me in reading through the original
language in hb2
around the doe was that there seemed to
be
a confluence in the language for
investigations and
other activities that would be
undertaken where
the doe and the puc were kind of used
interchangeably or in the same sentence
it would say that it would be both their
responsibilities to wage the
investigation and i thought that the
lack of um
[Music]
the lack of specificity in terms of
where those
you called it a red line you know like
what the separation was in terms of how
it was going to be done
i understand that there may be cases
where it would be one or the other but i
would think in the adjudicative
proceedings
it might not be the right place for the
doe to be stepping in so i
i wonder if you could say how you see
that working because
um you know i just want to be sure
that there's still sufficient
independence in the public utility
commission
to function i understand the stuff you
want to clean up but i think that that
could
introduce a new problem does that make
sense
i don't know and i appreciate the
question representative
i guess what i would say is the vast
majority
of functions are cordoned off to one or
the other and i think the sections in
hb2
where you do see the commission and the
department
are on things that regulated entities
have the duty to respond
to whichever one is conducting an
investigation
or that both entities would have access
to confidential information regarding a
proceeding right that
there's certainly confidential
information that the
department staff would need to work
through a docket
and then similarly but separately that
the commission would need
that confidential information to weigh
in and decide
but i do think the duties are clear
outside of those
few circumstances where there really
does need to be accountability to both
the department and the commission
that if it is a a rate proceeding
a rate case that certainly is something
that is decided by the commission
if it's something regarding policy like
renewable energy rebates
or offshore winds that's certainly
something that's done by the department
so i will admit there are a few rare
instances where it is a shared duty but
we feel that those are purposeful
and uh intentionally done for the
specific reasons that i outlined
great thank you mr chair can i have a
follow-up
go ahead follow up it's a different
topic but i might as well get in and get
get off the stage um the other question
that i had is you know some of us have
very
uh uh ambitious desires
for our department of energy in terms of
um
addressing the science around the
climate
issues and so my question would be
does the department have i've read
it's not like a mission but you know
i've read sort of what the department is
supposed to be organized to do
and much of it is very um
more tactical than strategic in my
humble opinion so
i'm just wondering if there are any
strategic
goals that that are higher than just the
administration of the policies and
programs that we have
under uh under our under our control
today um anything more ambitious in
terms of
um i would think a doe would want to be
level setting for the state
more than we have had in the last
several years so
can you speak to whether that is um
also part of the mission sure and i'll
answer that question in two different
parts
uh one being that the
office of strategic initiatives
historically has had to do with state
energy strategy
right it's this guiding document that's
updated every three years and
i believe the process actually just
kicked off
that duty is transferred to the
department of energy right and
that document certainly would still be
the state's you know
mark in the ground every three years of
what the next 10 years for the energy
policy statewide should be
but what i'll also say is that in the
current structure
employees at osi are directly hired by
the governor
right so there's no governor and council
confirmation for the director of osi the
deputy director
uh the job that chris and i have
previously had
where in the department of energy all of
those roles need to go
through that public process right so if
the executive council has
concerns whether it be climate change or
the rates
that you know residential customers have
to pay the leadership in this new entity
will be accountable and will have to
respond
to those concerns so to whatever the
public policy is that new hampshire
wants to chart forward
i think everyone can be rest assured the
next generation of leadership whoever
that may be
will go through that process and will be
more accountable to what those public
thank you thank you representative
representative plett
is recognized for a question thank you
mr chair i've got one that's ministerial
then i'm more substantive what
the ministerial ones i can barely read
those slides from the distance i'm from
can we get a copy happy to do so i'll
share the link
um with the chairman votes and and the
committee aide
thank you um as you know mr mayu
you both you and i served on that
commission
uh coming out of house bill 156
and it was finished its work last year
and
i got a distinct lack of enthusiasm from
the governor's office about doing any
department of energy and now this a year
later we have it what what happened what
transpired why is there
some change of opinion here sure
representative
and thank you and i enjoyed working on
that study commission together
um what i would say is i think the the
scope
that the 156 study commission pursued
was much broader
right if you remember some of the seats
on that commission was everything from
environmental services
to state parks what the governor put
forward in his budget is a much
narrower interpretation of what a
department of energy
would be comprised of right so we're
only looking at osi's energy components
and the puc you'll notice there's
nothing from environmental services
there's nothing
from any other state agency that comes
into this new department
so i don't know that anything's changed
necessarily other than that we were able
to
target the scope of this work
a bit more narrowly and i think that's
where
our support had been previously and just
wanted to make sure we were able to
bring that proposal forward
thank you thank you representative
samson
is recognized for a question
uh thank you mr chairman and if you'll
indulge me i
have several questions if i can ask them
um some are short and some are a little
more
extensive i guess but so number one um
uh i wanted to you mentioned that there
was going to be
um the budget would increase uh based on
additional federal funding uh what kind
of federal funding is that
and are we not getting that now is
does reorganizing the department energy
help us to get more funding
uh so i don't believe it's directly tied
to the organization
representative i believe the increases
come from
additional federal appropriations to
things like weatherization
and the low-income heating assistance
program
those programs are very popular at the
federal level
and i think partially driven by just
increasing federal budgets
but also in the early days of the
pandemic
we know the federal government
dramatically increased how much
heating assistance money was available
and some of that carries forward into
this biennium so those dollars
are narrowly targeted um but
really just augmenting existing programs
from the federal government
okay so i i i also i'm very supportive
of the idea of a department of energy i
think it's a good idea and i
and um i i hear uh represent platt
mentioning that uh
the the idea has changed a little bit
more from
lukewarm to enthusiastic which is great
um
the only thing i would i would kind of
criticize a little bit is the process
i understand that that that commission
did a good job and came up with ideas
but
to say that that was enough betting of
those ideas that you didn't have to have
a full-blown
hearing in front of our committee and
other similar committees before it was
proposed in the budget i think it's a
little stretching
the point i mean we could have had both
so it wasn't
one or the other so um but anyway i'm
supportive of the whole idea now you
said about streamlining the system
uh that there would be some benefits and
streamlining
process does that mean that some of the
issues that have been kind of lingering
for example um the long period of time
before people could get
energy rebates or incentives or energy
efficiency programs
do you anticipate this will help uh make
those programs more efficient
i definitely think that will happen
representative and
a lot of that is driven by the
regulatory entity
being strictly charged with regulatory
matters
and not needing to operate um
those policy elements that the puc
currently needs to right so
uh to get a residential rebate for for
solar or biomass or whatever else
you shouldn't have to have the whole
regulatory docket proceeding bringing
that into the department
makes the state more nimble obviously
there's going to be public input in
i think it's much more similar to the
way it works at the department of
environmental services
or any other agency that issues grants
or rebates back
to members of the public being nimble
and being able to set specific budgets
and not be tied up in a regulatory
proceeding i think certainly will have
its benefits
similarly you mentioned the eers i think
that's partially driven by having three
commissioners sitting again
right we know we're at 2 for a long time
we're very excited to have a full slate
of commissioners back at the puc and i
think
those issues will move forward
more effectively in the future under
this setup in this model as well
whereas where does reggie fit into this
program isn't that under des
right now yeah so most of what
most of the regulatory elements of
reggie are at des
but the rebates are issued through the
public utilities commission
as a credit on bills back to ratepayers
so that's the nexus there there would
still be collaboration
between both def and the new department
of energy
mr chairman hey thank you uh one last
question please
all right make this one your last one we
got to give other people a chance yes
i understand uh the uh you mentioned the
10-year strategy plan that's going to be
updated
currently comments are supposed to be
submitted to osi
and you said that's going to change
because that's going to be under the
department of energy
and the deadline for that is june 4th
are you planning to extend that deadline
since that
kind of comes into this mix of what's
going on right now
um i can't speak to when the deadline is
or if it would be extended but i think
the intent would be to have osi complete
this
uh public input phase before they would
sunset at the end of june
and then turn those materials over to
the new department to
carry on uh it from there but i can't
i don't know specifically on what the
deadlines are okay thank you very much
i can actually answer that question for
you representative samsic at an easy
board meeting
last friday mark sanborn who
works currently for osi said that he
would be
asking the governor's office to extend
the deadline for
public comments on the state energy
strategy
we don't know what the date will be but
it will be extended
okay representative callie pittsford is
recognized for a question and don't
forget to unmute
thank you one of the one of the things
that really bothers me is that recently
we've had an
incident where the governor has
said do not discuss a certain issue
at the top of this whole organizational
structure
is the governor and council should the
governor decide
that an issue whatever that issue is
should not be brought up
either to the public utilities
commission or to the
uh new department of energy would that
hold would the governor be able to
editing on a particular agency
and that has happened and that really is
a concern of me
because there are some things that may
never happen but
they deserve discussion so can somebody
i i'm not specifically sure what you
might be referring to representative
callie pitts
i can say unequivocally the governor
would never have authority over
a regulatory proceeding so any docket
that's open at the puc the governor
can't communicate with those
commissioners
outside of a hearing room the same way
that none of us can
right the governor doesn't have a
as for agency heads obviously agency
heads
whether it be department of business
economic affairs or cultural resources
or
a new department of energy they would
report to the governor
um as members of the executive branch
but
i don't know what you might be referring
to as far as far as editing goes
well may i yes follow up
i did not want to bring up a specific
incident but the des was recently told
not to discuss a certain program
and whether a program is good or not
good sometimes it
it needs discussion so at the top of
the way i see it and stop me if i'm
wrong is the governor
and if the governor doesn't want
something to be discussed or doesn't
want a docket to be open
can he tell the osi
or the order uh department of energy
we're not going to even deal with that
uh so the governor certainly couldn't
stop a docket from being opened
um as for what policies the state
pursues
any chief executive does have you know
some discretion
obviously within the bounds of the law
and and the governor ultimately is
accountable to the voters on those
but i think that's all just in the
normal course of government
that different chief executives would
pursue different policies but obviously
we're all bound by the laws that are
written by the legislature enacted by
the
executive and upheld by the courts
can i one more follow okay if i can just
interject the issue the specific issue
that you're talking about which was
house bill
373 the senate actually
amended house bill 373 to take the
governor out of the picture
and made the executive council the
uh adjudicating body for
that issue for that issue but i just
wanted to let you know about that
go ahead and ask thank you the the other
again the puc is is a quasi-judicial
branch
and should be separate from any
should be separate from any political
persuasion so
are you saying to me that under this new
structure
the governor would have no influence
over what the uh puc decides
would not be able to tell them i
i'll say that unequiv unequivocally yes
representative and i think that's one of
the most important reasons why pursuing
this policy change
is so vital because
when the puc is not only adjudicating
but also
setting policy things like residential
rebates or the renewable portfolio
standard and things like that
um you know though there there is a
blurring of of what you know they're
responsible to the governor for
or not in this new structure there's a
bright red line that if it's regulatory
and it's at the puc
that's a black box but if it's at the
department and its policy
things that are in the normal course of
what an executive branch agency would do
those are the areas where there could be
communication right if there's a
constituent issue
um with obtaining a rebate for for solar
or something like that
the governor's office and citizen
services could facilitate that
in a way that at the pc it's currently
structured
that's a very uncertain conversation
depending on what dockets are open or
anything like that
but certainly no regulatory interference
with any open docket
and again we think that this proposal
clarifies
and only strengthens that barrier
thank you thank you representative kelly
pitts
chair recognizing representative
oxendine for a question
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you mr mayor for taking my question
um currently the puc
has regulatory matters on its dockets
but it also has what i
would consider policy issues like
um how best to advance energy storage um
grid mods uh you know
various things are are things like that
going to be taken away from them and
handled at the doe or will they still
have those sort of
two different areas of expertise
underneath of them
well i think what i would say on that
representative and that's a great
question
especially for ongoing investigations
and i'll use the statewide energy
platform from senate bill 286
from two years ago right now the puc is
it has an open docket as to whether or
not that's
costs beneficial or in the public
interest
the way that the language is written
into hb2 is that
the puc is the arbiter the way the
statute was written
to decide if it is something the state
should do
and then the department of energy would
be the implementer
of a proposal like that when it comes to
things like time of use rates or
energy efficiency or anything else
things that would need to
be incorporated into the utility tariff
right the puc
is the ultimate arbiter of that but i do
think that the doe
would be the entity with both the
resources the expertise and the duty
as it's envisioned in hb2
to do a lot of the legwork on things
like that so if it's
new rate structures that the state may
want to pursue as a matter of public
policy
the department would present that case
through a docket to the commission
and the commission again would issue an
order
either granting or or denying
that type of a proposal follow up
go ahead thank you very much um
let's take for an example the net
metering docket which has been ongoing
for a while a lot of money has been
invested in
pilots and studies and at some point
hopefully in the very near future
they're going to be coming to an outcome
um that because it's ongoing that will
proceed
i unders as i understand you that would
proceed entirely within the pucs
purview the puc would have to issue the
final order
on what those rates would be right any
rate setting
matter is for the commission to decide
um the department of energy might be the
ones that coordinate
with the consultants and the different
you know contractors that have been
brought in to do those analyses
because again the department staff would
present
the uh the evidence and the
justification
from the state's purview but
the department employees would never be
advising the commission on how they
should rule
right so there is that division of
responsibility
who is presenting the case and who is uh
deciding what the outcome would be
uh and that's the bright red line that
that we're um
proposing through this reorganization
into the department of energy
so to answer your question i guess in
fewer words the puc would decide what
the net metering rate is
um but the department might be doing
some of the work uh preparing what that
follow up just to clarify okay uh make
this your
your last one thank you thank you um
so even though this is an ongoing
proceeding we're going to be
changing how it's we mean the rfp is
already out the consultant's already
hired they're going to come back with
their information
it's going to be the doe people who will
take that information and then
present it to the puc rather than that
information going directly to the puc
uh i can't speak to that specific
instance
but at the end of the day the puc will
be the entity that decides
what net metering rates would be thank
you but i
i i don't know enough about the specific
details of that
pending docket other than that the puc
will be the ones that make their final
okay thank you representative
representative pimentel is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman uh
mr miller you mentioned that part of the
funding for the new
department of energy is coming from
the reggie funds and
currently the reggie funds either go
a small portion of it goes back to the
ratepayers and the rest
goes to i think new hampshire saves is
that correct
so this
is going to be a new tap on that
fund no no so there it wouldn't be a new
tap on it my comments there
are just to say that because the
department is the pass-through
right the department receives those
dollars from the auction
and then issues rebates back to
customers
that appears on the state's books as
both the revenue
right the source from the auction and an
expense
in terms of that grant or that rebate
but there wouldn't be any new
administrative draw
on those funds
just that the department facilitates
that transaction essentially
okay my my concern
uh just to follow up mr chairman
but my concern is that if in fact
that that revenue from reggie is being
used
for administrative purposes uh even if
it's a small percentage
the concern is like so many other things
where
the state has a tap to for funds whether
it's
the the uh property tax or
sales taxes that
get diverted from one thing to
balancing the state budget and that's my
only concern
so and representative let me see if i
can allay some of your concerns there
just to say that while the entity that
administers it is changing
there are no changes to the eligible
uses for those funds
or any of that existing uh
infrastructure that goes to administer
this right so all we're really doing is
changing
the name of who does it but not what it
can be used for what's allowed
and with any dedicated fund in the state
it's prescribed
and restricted to a specific purpose
so would never be going to be used to
balance a budget
thank you very much thank you
representative
representative mann you had your hand up
no i got answered thank you okay thank
you
representative mcgee you have a question
yes thank you mr chairman
it was just a follow-up on the reggie
again didn't
the last uh auction didn't we end up
with
a significantly higher amount paid in
the last quarter than we were
used to i thought it was significantly
higher like
from 14 to 21 or something like that so
it's a
bigger chunk of money that's in that um
kitty right now right is that true
that is true and i think that here
looking at the department's analysis
the current biennium revenues totaled
16.5 million
in fiscal 20 and 12.7 in fiscal 21
the department is estimating 20.8
million each year
in the next two years so yes the
significant increase is what they're
uh projecting to see come into the state
through that auction
and again that's both a revenue and also
an expense
okay thank you uh any further questions
from members of the committee
uh representative mann you have your
thank you um i guess um
my point of view is that energy and the
environment are very closely related
so the the uh the whole reggie the use
of reggie funds
and the uh addition of systems benefits
charge funds
that's outside the department is that
correct that's
you guys administer it but policy is
made elsewhere
like by the way yeah so certainly
legislative policy has a large role to
play
des addresses a lot of the compliance
side of that program
and the puc currently or the department
of energy
in this new reorganization be the one
administering those funds
whether it be to energy efficiency or
and again no change to how that all
operates other than that it's going from
the puc
to the department of energy
um follow-up go ahead
uh thank you mr chairman thank you by
the way matthew for
it does seem to me that the rebates to
the
ratepayers is um a sort of a historical
accident
uh that happened a few years ago and is
the
reggie funds were originally intended to
be used pretty much entirely for
um environmental issues so um
there's no hard um
again that decision on exactly how
that's gonna that money
should be used whether it should be
rebated or turned into
funding for the environment
that's outside your scope the scope of
the department correct
that's correct that is all prescribed by
the legislature
and i would never refer to any
legislation as a historical accident
obviously there's a very rigorous
process but yes it is all prescribed by
legislation how those dollars flow
to any of their given endpoints okay
thank you thank you representative um
representative mcgee you have your hand
up you have another question or is that
a leftover
no i i left it up because i wanted to
just remind
uh mr melo that he had mentioned
in addition to sending us the slides
which were requested that he might send
along that memo from commissioner martin
and i would appreciate that so i just
had a little note here and i thought i'd
mention it before we conclude
happy to do it thanks thanks thanks for
that reminder
are there any additional questions from
the committee
seeing none i would like to extend my
heartfelt
thanks and congratulations to the two of
you for
putting this together and presenting it
to the committee we really appreciate
you being here today
thank you thank you so much for the
invitation thank you thank you for
coming
appreciate it you guys have a great day
okay so um
we are done let's take up one more
issue before we adjourn for the day
well i don't need you now if you have
any uh
familiarity with something called a
doodle poll
would you raise your hand and i don't
mean your uh
your zoom hand but your regular hand
i'll pick up the girl
i don't know if you see me when i'm on
the side
okay i guess some people know what a
doodle pole is the reason i'm asking
is because we could use a doodle pool to
determine
whether or not june 7th june 14th or
june 21st
or some combination of those three might
be a good time to get together for
uh a work session on retained bills
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
try to put together a doodle poll
although i will admit i've never done
that before
but i'm going to i i've used them but
i've never actually constructed one
i'm going to try to do that and i'll
send it to all of you
and we'll see what
which of those three dates or maybe all
of them will work for
future work sessions and then we'll go
from there representative partial
did you have a comment don't forget to
unmute
[Music]
feel free to contact me if you have any
questions i've set them up on
quite a few different occasions um if
that helps
doodle polls so you've set them up on
several occasions so feel free to
contact me
if you need help it's not tired you'll
be fine
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so with that i think we can
now
uh bid you all good afternoon and thanks
to you all for
uh being here today i think we've
concluded our business
for this uh session of the biennium
the only matters still before us will be
house sessions on june 3rd
june 4th june 10th and june
i will very likely be concurring on
house bill
315 the changes made by the senate and
also on house bill
373 they made a minor change
as well to that bill so we'll probably
concur on those
and and we'll be done and it's been a
great year
i've enjoyed working with you all zoom
has made it a little bit
odd at times but we got through it and
so
uh thanks to you all i look forward to
seeing you on june 3rd
and or 4th at the bedford
sports complex in bedford representative
callie pitts
i have a question on the concurrences
because that it really bothers me
when you concur on a bill do you concur
for the committee
yes yes and if the committee does not
concur
or a piece of the committee doesn't
concur according to house rules the
decision to concur
non-concur or request a committee of
conference is the committee chair's
responsibility
and my understanding is and and
precedence has been in this committee
that when that's done the committee has
always been consulted
how do you feel about it what do you do
do you agree with this
uh because it's not a unilateral
i i i'm gonna express my feelings that
that
we have always been told this is what
we're going to concur on and this is
what it's about
right and do you agree with the
concurrence or don't you the final
decision
is the chairs but the chair usually
consults with the rest of the committee
that's all i'm saying and that's been 23
years
mr chairman and that's why i brought it
up and discussed it
to get a sense of of whether anybody had
any objections to concurrence i didn't
hear any so
my plan was to go forward with
concurrence
uh representative platt um mr chairman i
just point out that the
first two years i served on this when uh
the
the sides were flipped i didn't find
that at all
i had the chairman at the time say this
is what we're doing
okay thank you and allowed people to
speak
if they didn't agree with it we had that
discussion on hb 315
anybody else have anything to say before
have a good weekend okay have a great
weekend everybody
and we go happy memorial day we'll see
a garden and start digging guys already
done it
mine's all planted all we need is some
water to make it grow
yeah that's uh okay thanks again
everybody